[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu einer neuen Folge 8:15 Uhr
meine Gäste heute Abend sind die
FDP-Politikerin Linda Teuteberg
kultjournalist Hans-ulrich Jörges
glücksradstar und Schauspielerin Maren
Gilzer und Unternehmer Michael Schröder
wir sprechen heute über die Doppelmoral
von Robert Habeck die transchwimmerin
Lia Thomas und die Lage der Menschen die
sich gegen die corona-impfung
entschieden haben das Konzept der
Sendung ist sehr einfach aber falls sie
doch das erste Mal zugeschaltet haben
was ich nicht hoffe jeder von uns hat
ein Thema mitgebracht was in schockiert
bewegt oder über das man einfach mal mit
anderen Menschen am Dienstagabend
debattieren möchte mein Aufreger des
Tages ist heute Deutschlands aktuell für
mich unfähigste Ministerin unsere
verteilungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht ich möchte jetzt nicht schon
wieder von den Helmen anfangen erstens
etwas weiter zurückgehen auch wenn
Kompetenz bei der Vergabe von
Ministerposten deutschen Politikbetrieb
der leider sowieso eher nebensächlich
ist ist es doch etwas Besonderes wie
wenig entsprechend Frau Lambrecht auch
außerhalb der Helme für das
Verteidigungsministerium ist ihre
münsterkarriere begann im
Justizministerium wo sie besonders mit
fragwürdigen Beförderungen von
Parteifreunden für Aufsehen sorgte laut
einem tagesschaubericht soll sie gut
zuhören angeblich 16 Personen befördert
haben bis ihr Parteifreund Person Nummer
17 von der Qualifikation Her endlich an
der Reihe war sein Spitzname soll seit
dem gewesen sein Nummer 17 nach ihrer
Zeit im Justizministerium wollte sie
denn eigentlich wieder mit der Politik
aufhören und als Juristin arbeiten doch
so viel Glück hatte Deutschland leider
nicht Olaf Scholz machte sie zur
Verteidigungsministerin und verpasste
meiner Meinung nach damit die Chance auf
eine fehlgeführung der Bundeswehr die
Süddeutsche Zeitung berichtete dazu die
ersten Tage Ministerium begann frostig
die alte Führungsmannschaft wurde sofort
kaltgestellt insgesamt scheint Lambrecht
eine Aversion gegen alles Militärische
zu haben mit der Aufgabe sich
Dienstgrade Haken schien sie sichtlich
überfordert und nach Berichten von
Business Insider prüft Ihr sie sogar den
Generalinspektor aus ihrem Beraterkreis
zu entfernen ich finde die Bundeswehr
braucht endlich jemanden mit Expertise
der diese Aufgabe gewachsen ist und ja
auch jemand der schon mal an der Waffe
gedient hat
dem kann ich dir nur zustimmen
grundsätzlich sollten wir immer im
Unternehmertum eine Kompetenz mit sich
bringen und auch daraus resultierend
wird man bewertet ich denke
Verteidigungsministerium ist eine der
einzigsten Ministerien wo man zwingend
eine Erfahrung mitbringen sollte
eigentlich auch
im Gesundheitsministerium da ist aber
Zeit meine separate Debatte zu fühlen
weil da sage ich mal der Lauterbach ist
ja
Mediziner
vielleicht zu arg
spezifisch ausgerichtet deshalb ja aber
grundsätzlich stimme ich im Zug man
sollte auf jeden Fall Dienst an der
Wache Waffe oder den Wehrdienst gemacht
haben um dem
den Anforderungen eines Ministeriums
entsprechen zu können ich glaube das ist
ein Ergebnis der falsch verstandenen
Quotenpolitik der SPD und auch der CDU
inzwischen das ist ja inzwischen schon
die dritte Frau die auf diesem Stuhl
sitzt im Verteidigungsministerium alle
drei haben einen Scherbenhaufen
hinterlassen begann mit Ursula von der
Leyen die eigentlichen intelligente
Politikern ist aber auch kein Zugang zu
dem Thema hatte und das Angela Merkel
Kanzlerin war in den letzten Jahren hat
auch damit zu tun in welchem Zustand wir
heute die Bundeswehr vorfinden Frau Lomb
Frau Lamprecht wäre ja nicht auf diesen
Stuhl gekommen wenn die SPD nicht sich
im Zwang gesehen hätte
halbe halbe Männer und Frauen auf
Ministerposten zu heben wenn Lars
Klingbeil
Verteidigungsminister geworden wäre was
ich mir gewünscht hatte persönlich
Verteidigungsausschuss der hat sich mit
den Themen ständig beschäftigt der kommt
aus einer Soldatenfamilie der schon als
Jugendlicher da aufgewachsen in dem
Milieu wenn der klingenballminister wäre
wäre uns auch Lauterbach erspart
geblieben als Gesundheitsminister welche
Freude müsste man heute sagen weil der
wer eine Frau Gesundheitsministerin
geworden wer immer das gewesen wäre es
wäre auf jeden Fall besser gewesen als
Lauterbach finde ich wir brauchen auf
jeden Fall vor allem viel mehr
Wertschätzung für unsere Soldaten und
Soldaten und die Bundeswehr weil was uns
jetzt bevorsteht ist ja wirklich
weiterhin die Debatte manche von daher
schon wieder zu zweifeln an daran dass
die Sondervermögen wichtig und richtig
ist für die Bundeswehr es geht nicht um
Aufrüstung es geht überhaupt mal um
ausrüsten dass unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten angemessen ihre Aufgabe
wahrnehmen können ich glaube da haben
wir noch viel zu tun dass wir richtige
Wehrhaftigkeit nicht verwechseln mit
Militarismus sondern wissen wir brauchen
eine wehrhafte Bundeswehr um unsere
Freiheit um den Frieden zu vertreiben
ein quotenministerium ist die ist mir
auch schon
ich glaube das gilt für verschiedene
Positionen und öfter mal und ich bin
auch nicht so der Meinung dass Politiker
Fachleute sein müssen aber Sie müssen
sie müssen durchsetzungsfähig sein ich
glaube sie müssen guten Überblick haben
da ist eigentlich das was Frau Lamprecht
mitbringt Juristin gar nicht so schlecht
man muss sich nämlich auch nicht von
Beamten erzählen lassen was geht oder
was nicht geht aber am Ende ist das
keine fachspezifische Frage ist eine
Frage glaube ich wirklich der der
Erfahrung der Herangehensweise einen
guten Überblick zu haben
durchsetzungsfähig zu sein und das
braucht die Bundeswehr besonders bei uns
im Prinzip hat Frau Lambrecht alles
nicht was sie jetzt aufgezählt haben und
das der Bundeskanzler jetzt begonnen hat
die Verwendung der 100 Milliarden für
die Rüstungsprojekte der Bundeswehr
selbst in die Hand zu nehmen mit dem
generales bekehrt darüber zu reden da
sitzt Frau Lamprecht mit dabei muss ich
ja wohl auch aber er hat das selbst in
die Hand genommen hat natürlich auch
damit zu tun wie er seine eigene
Verteidigungsministerin einschätzt da
kann ja viel mal vom Brett rutschen das
sind von den 100 Milliarden Stellen mal
50 weg und man weiß gar nicht wohin also
muss man sehr aufpassen auch das ist
übrigens du hast eine Menge von
Fehlleistungen aufgezählt dass die
Ministerin nicht mal einen Ansatz
unternommen hat eine Gruppe von
kompetenten Leuten zusammenzurufen die
den Auftrag haben die Verwendung der 100
Milliarden zu klären und konnte sich
nicht mehr als die ganze Titel merken ja
aber das hat wahrscheinlich auch der
Grund dass Deutschland sowieso in den
letzten Jahren sich sehr pazifistisch
aufgestellt hat immer wenn es hieß mehr
Waffen und dann war man ja ganz ein ganz
böser Mensch und man sagt dann ja auch
ja Frauen die sind gerade in dem Bereich
ja viel besser weil die Reden die
greifen nicht gleich zur Waffe die sind
diplomatisch
nee das nennt sich feministische
Außenpolitik
ich glaube das hat uns in den
vergangenen Jahren sehr verfolgt und
diese üble Rechnung müssen wir jetzt
einfach bezahlen dass wir uns einfach zu
sehr auf den Frieden vertraut haben und
gemeint haben wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass der Frieden erhalten bleibt in dem
wir reden und das können Frauen
vielleicht besser vieles falsch
verstanden wir haben ja auch gedacht
dass wir von Russland abhängig sind ist
nur gut für uns weil die Russen liefern
zuverlässig ja das tun sie schon aber
von wem kriegt man das Zeug jetzt also
wir haben ja auch viele geglaubt wenn
wir wirtschaftlich mit den Russen
zusammenarbeiten dann sind sie auch
wirtschaftlich von uns abhängig und
deswegen lassen sie uns irgendwo
diplomatie ist gut aber man muss
natürlich ernst genommen werden damit
das was bringt und dafür muss man so
stark sein dass für die andere Seite
nicht verhandeln keine Option ist und
das ist vernachlässigt worden und ich
glaube darüber brauchen wir noch eine
echte Debatte da gibt es noch einige die
noch nicht so weit sind dass wir jetzt
wirklich ganz konsequent die Bundeswehr
so ausstatten und nicht schon wieder
überlegen wie können wir das für
irgendwelche anderen Zwecke noch ein
bisschen verteilen
einschränken wenn sage ich mal niemand
ist davon ausgegangen dass jetzt hier
ein Angriffskrieg aus Russland ausgeht
und dass die Bundeswehr jetzt so
explizit in Fokus gerät ja man ging ja
davon aus es läuft immer so da war die
Vorgängerin war ja auch eine Frau gerade
war auch eine Frau ja der Bundeswehr auf
jeden Fall beliebter gewesen sein also
ich habe immer Frau Kramp-Karrenbauer
ehrlich gesagt bei manchen
Bundeswehrsoldaten sehr gutes gehört Uli
da habe ich etwas anderes Bild auf jeden
Fall gespiegelt bekommen von einzelnen
auch vom Bundestagsabgeordneten die
sollen nicht ganz so
daneben wohl gewesen sein
gewehrt haben das gehört ja zur Realität
der letzten Jahre dazu dass nicht wenig
blockiert wurde auch was die Ausrüstung
geholt auch aus dem Saarland wie sie
selber und ich weiß bin nicht so sicher
ob das nun das richtige Merkmal war um
ein Generalinspektor auszuzeichnen das
aus dem Saarland kommt aber manchmal
vertraut man ist keine besonderen
Militärmacht niemals gewesen ein
Ostdeutschland haben wir besondere
Erfahrungen mit Führungspersonal aus dem
Saarland ja stimmt vielleicht sollte man
auch über die Rolle der unsere Soldaten
mal debattieren weil zum Beispiel so
etwas wie hoch Wasser oder Erdbeben oder
andere Katastrophen passieren warum
dauert es dann so lange bis man die ins
Boot holen kann damit die einen helfen
als wenn sie es schon nicht im Krieg
ziehen so weiter haben wir sehr viel
gemacht die letzten Jahre es ist ja eher
so dass viele sich dran gewöhnt haben
immer nach der Bundeswehr zu rufen Frau
giffer ja auch hier in Berlin jetzt beim
Thema Flüchtlinge jetzt umso wichtiger
ist dass wir in Erinnerung rufen auch da
leistet die Bundeswehr viel aber es ist
nicht ihr kernauftrag und wir müssen sie
jetzt mal ihren kernauftrag erfüllen
lassen und dafür richtig ausstatten sie
wird gerne bei Katastrophenschutz bei
irgendwelchen personalknappheiten auch
das Impfen und so genutzt aber wir
brauchen Sie natürlich für ihren
kernauftrag ich wollte noch eins zwei
Quoten Frage sagen ich bin sehr dafür
Quoten anzulegen bei der Auswahl von
Mandatsträgerinnen und Mandatsträger
also bei Bundestagsabgeordneten
Kandidaten für Parlamente bei
Ämtern bin ich ganz anderer Meinung da
bin ich der Meinung da kommt es auf
Qualifikation an da sollten die Bewer
auch schon mal was mit dem Thema zu tun
gehabt haben und nicht nachgeschrieben
man sollte die Quote von unten ansetzen
damit sie irgendwann oben ankommen
ist es eine andere Frage man muss
jemanden finden im
verteilungsministerium der schon mal mit
der Bundeswehr zu tun hatte der davon
was versteht der auch mal eine Waffe in
der Hand hatte möglicherweise auf jeden
Falls der nicht völlig neu lernen muss
aber die Frage ist ja schon bei der bei
der Quoten Sache die du gerade
angesprochen hast es gibt ja die Theorie
dass man unten anfangen muss auch im
Unternehmen also dass man anfangen
sollte ab dem niedrigsten Level damit es
sich dann hochziehen kann und dann oben
die Leistungsträger beide Geschlechter
haben und das eine Quote oben nichts
bringen würde ja richtig könnte man denn
dann nicht das habe ich mich oft gefragt
und die Frage würde ich gerne an Frau
Teuteberg spielen als Politikerin warum
gibt es nicht in jedem
Wirtschaftsunternehmen gibt es ein
Anforderungsprofil also ich kann jetzt
nicht hochgehen zu Herr Boje und sagen
so ich bin eine Frau ich möchte jetzt
gerne Chefredakteurin werden war zwar
erst 2017 im voltariat aber ich wäre es
jetzt gerne schon mal also wieso gibt es
kein Anforderungsprofil wie in jedem
Wirtschaftsunternehmen auch für die
Politik das habe ich mich immer gefragt
zum Beispiel verteilungsministerium
warum muss es nicht jemand sein Tudor
als vorgemacht in Kanada er hat ja sein
Kabinett damals so aufgestellt dass die
auch vor Erfahrung hat warum gibt es
nicht wie so ein Bewerbungsbogen wo man
ein paar Fähigkeiten haben muss na die
Politik hat da eigene Gesetze und
Logiken wobei ehrlich gesagt bei die als
Kanzler oder Kanzlerin oder
Regierungschefs besetzen können wen sie
dann nehmen die können natürlich
trotzdem sinnvolle Kriterien anlegen
aber ansonsten ist es natürlich so in
Parteien und in vielen Bereichen dass
sie aus Ehrenamt das ist um Ehrenamt
geht und dass sie erst mal sehen müssen
welche Menschen engagieren sich und wer
will dann für etwas kandidieren oder
Verantwortung übernehmen also sie haben
auch nicht wie in der Wirtschaft
natürlich die üblichen Möglichkeiten
über Gehalt und andere Dinge Menschen zu
fördern oder Leistung zu belohnen oder
schlecht Leistung zu bestrafen also da
gibt es viele Gründe aber wenn es um
Ämter geht um Regierungsämter hat das
natürlich viel mit den Personen zu tun
die entscheiden wer dort das wird und
wenn sich gerne die Handlungsfähigkeit
erhalten und möglichst wenig Kriterien
haben die Ihnen die Handlungsfähigkeit
einschränken deshalb wird es wie wir das
erlebt haben bei Olaf Scholz bis zum
letzten Moment hin und her gechincht und
dann war die Frage also
Lauterbach wird Gesundheitsminister da
muss eine Frau Verteidigung machen da
sitzen wir jetzt
in diesem Loch sitzen wir jetzt und zwar
sind sie in Wahrheit zwei Löcher ja das
war Uli jetzt habe ich ganz wichtig noch
mal mit der quotentheorie auch zu
schließen die Lambrecht Debatte und wir
gehen weiter zu dem Unternehmer der
Runde und zwar freue ich mich jetzt auf
ihre These Herr Schröder die ja was mit
Robert Habeck zu tun hat dementsprechend
hat uns ja beide Politiker aufgeregt die
Woche ja ich sag mal so Robert Habeck
hat mich leicht irritiert und ich war
erschrocken es ist geplant Strom
Gas aus Katar
ist die Frage ist jetzt die richtige
Entscheidung wie wir alle wissen wir
sind abhängig von fossilen
Energieträgern wie Kohle Putin Gas und
Öl wir wissen genau diese Ressourcen
sind begrenzt was wiederum zu Resultat
führt dass es explodierende Strom und
Energiepreise gibt die Frage die wir uns
stellen sollten wie schaffen wir es eine
kluge und saubere Klimapolitik zu
gestalten ohne gleichzeitig auf den
Wohlstand zu verzichten bzw ihn zu
gefährden kurzfristig ab insbesondere
auch langfristig ich sage saubere
Energie aus der Wüste desertech die
Vision von Desertec ist vor 15 Jahren
ins Leben gerufen und wurde von der
Politik bisher nicht ausreichend
unterstützt
nun ist die Zeit dazu reif definitiv die
Lösung großflächige Wind und
Solaranlagen in der Wüste bevorzugt in
Nordafrika der Transport der generierten
Energie erfolgt über Unterwasserkabel
über Stromtrassen oder per Schiff
wir haben ausreichend frei verfügbare
Flächen in den Wüsten um den kompletten
Energiebedarf der Erde zu lösen bzw zu
decken Deutschland und Europa muss
endlich aufwachen schauen wir nach China
in China entstehen derzeit 450 Gigawatt
an Wind und Solarkraftwerken das
entspricht in etwa 400 Atomkraftwerken
das heißt china macht sich komplett
unabhängig von energieimpern aber auch
von fossilen Energieträgern will
Deutschland und Europa dem Wettbewerb
erneut hinterherrennen
ich sage nein ich sage setzt auf Strom
aus der Wüste macht euch machen wir uns
gemeinsam unabhängig ich habe kürzlich
gelesen einen Journal aus Amerika sagte
Deutschland macht weltweit die
schlechteste Energiepolitik lieber Herr
Habeck das sollten wir ändern ich stehen
mit Rat und Tat zur Seite
der Kniefall waren ein bisschen aktiv
aber Robert Habeck ist natürlich auf
schwieriger Mission und die Misere mit
der erst jetzt zu tun hat die hat viele
Mütter und Väter das sind natürlich die
die nur über Ausstieg reden geredet
haben in den letzten Jahren ob bei Kohle
oder Atom da waren die Grünen dabei aber
natürlich auch viele andere die zu große
Abhängigkeit von Russland da waren viele
dabei das falsch einzuschätzen und
Atomkraft wurde beschleunigt der
Ausstieg da haben wir viel zu tun und
die Optionen die sie genannt haben die
wurden zu wenig verfolgt also
technologieoffenheit und die sonst so
viel gerühmte Vielfalt also hier auch
diversifizieren bei den Energieträgern
dass es sträflich vernachlässigt worden
aber da war waren die Grünen nicht die
einzigen die ihren Anteil daran haben
und Robert Habeck muss jetzt in kurzer
Zeit dafür sorgen dass wir Alternativen
finden insofern ich würde ihn nicht so
hart verurteilen aber die Energiepolitik
der letzten Jahre die ist gescheitert
ich würde Ihnen noch schärfer
verurteilen also wahrscheinlich jeder
hier weil ich und ich finde das mit
Katar wir machen es wahrscheinlich
gleich zusammen ich denke mir es ist
jetzt blöd wenn ich darüber rede wie
schlimm es Doris was er habe mit Katar
macht lassen wir doch einmal Herrn
Habeck erklären warum er hat ja ein
Video aufgenommen mit einem Land wie
Kartei jetzt Geschäfte machen möchte die
Menschenrechte werden da ja nicht so
richtig gewahrt aber hören wir doch mal
wie das in Herr harbecks Worten klingt
das ist natürlich eine politisch sagen
wir
interessante Region dass ich immer
angesprochen habe sind die Arbeits- und
Menschenrechte die natürlich ein großes
Thema sind es gibt nur 300.000 Kataris
10% der Bevölkerung 3 Millionen Menschen
leben hier der Rest arbeitet hier häufig
nicht zu so ganz guten Bedingungen
die Arbeits- und Menschenrechte in Katar
die Diskussion ist uns bekannt seitdem
wir über die Fußball-WM reden das ist
das halte ich auch nicht für relevant
sondern ich mir wird es ein bisschen
schwungrig wenn wir dabei sind ein
politisches Risiko Russland durch ein
anderes politisches Risiko arabische
Länder einzutauschen da kann jeden Tag
am politischer Umsturz stattfinden in
den Emiraten aber auch in Nordafrika
kein Staat ist demokratisch sicher und
verlässlich und ich finde wir sollten
aus dem russland-abenteuer insofern
lernen dass wir uns bei den
energieporten ausschließlich auf dem und
zwar auf sauber regierte demokratische
Staaten verlassen das sind die USA
Kanada Australien
Europa natürlich und ansonsten sollten
wir die Finger davon lassen vielleicht
kleinere Mengen die nicht maßgeblich
sind für unsere Gesamtversorgung aber
das sollten wir gelernt haben und damit
bringen wir es auch zusammen ich weiß
nicht ob wir nicht in zehn Jahren
komisch aus der Wäsche gucken wenn das
was sie auf der in der Wüste aufgebaut
haben von irgendwelchen Islamisten
abgekappt wird die dort die Macht
übernommen haben
für sauberen Wüstenstrom für Europa wäre
natürlich am besten Nordafrika aber es
gibt ganz andere Wüsten Atacama Wüste in
Chile da gibt es ein Pilotprojekt von
Volkswagen Porsche Siemens gemeinsam mit
Enel dem Energieversorger aus Italien
die machen einen Pilotprojekt um zu
generieren also es ist nicht zwingender
Nordafrika
limitiert da der Mittlere Osten macht
sehr genau so das sind wiederum die
Chinesen involviert Shanghai electric
baut gemeinsam mit dem saudi-arabischen
Aqua Energieversorger dort genau das was
wir schon seit Jahren fordern das ist
die unab Möglichkeit und man kann zwar
transportieren man kann Wasserstoff
generieren und die politische
Instabilität ist was sie gerade sagen
widerspreche ich Tunesien Marokko
überall macht man Urlaub russland hat
man jahrelang sage ich mal unterstützt
doch mal immer Marco konnte man vom
halben Jahr schon keinen Urlaub mehr
machen im Marokko weil die
diplomatischen Beziehungen quasi
eingefroren waren weil sich deutsche
Touristen da gar nicht um behindert
aufhalten konnten also das ist abhängig
geht wir haben auch in den letzten
Jahren viel zu vielen über Ausstiege in
Deutschland geredet und nicht wo wir neu
einsteigen wollen und dazu gehört
übrigens auch mit der gehörige Portion
Anti-Amerikanismus weil nämlich zum
Beispiel das Thema Flüssiggas sehr früh
generell verteufelt wurde jetzt als
plötzlich Terminal wird gebaut für LNG
flüssiggas ist bis vor kurzem immer
blockiert worden und übrigens nicht
zuletzt auch mit dem Argument mag sein
dass es teuer ist das ist auch aufwendig
aber im Verhältnis dazu von wem wir uns
sonst abhängig machen und wenn man dann
mal wieder die Gretchenfrage stellt wo
rufen wir an wenn wir Schutz brauchen
wir Probleme haben in Moskau oder in
Washington dann dürfte die Antwort klar
sein trotzdem haben wir wurde über Jahre
mehrheitlich ausgeschlossen das
Flüssiggas überhaupt ein Teil unserer
Energieversorgung sein kann und aus
dieser
Illusion und aus dieser Naivität Wachen
jetzt viele auf das wichtigste ist die
Unabhängigkeit und das geht es
Hauptsächlich Deutschland und Europa
muss ich unabhängig machen wie China
china macht sie ja jetzt die macht sich
komplett unabhängig unabhängig von
Russland von denen die eine Bedrohung
sind die Amerikaner hatten doch auch
recht damit indirekt jetzt ist das das
große Thema bei uns dass wir natürlich
über diese fossilen Energieträger sehr
wohl die Aufrüstung finanzieren in
Russland also da war ja was dran während
wir gleichzeitig die zwei Prozent in der
NATO nicht einhalten als deutsche also
dieser dieser Ärger in Amerika der
übrigens nicht nur was mit Trump zu tun
hatte sondern über alle politischen
Lager hinweg über Deutschland und Europa
gab es da Unmut in Amerika der war ja
nicht unberechtigt aber letztendlich
haben wir immer noch keine schnelle
Lösung all es gibt tolle Ideen und tolle
Erfindungen liegen auf dem Tisch auch
gerade was ein Wasserstoff angeht hat
ja genau schon vor 20 Jahren bin ich da
Shuttleservice mit BMW abgeholt worden
denkt warum ist es so leise ja der ist
mit Wasserstoff betrieben aber die
Lobbyisten die haben sich einfach
durchgesetzt sie wollten weiter eben
Benzin und Öl und Verbrennungsmotor und
und da konnten die sich damit nicht
durchsetzen aber die ganzen Pläne davon
liegen seit vielen vielen Jahren in den
Schubläden aber das jetzt so schnell zu
aktivieren so schnell wie wir es
brauchen das ist eben das Problem zum
Teil sehr schnell Kohle können Sie
sofort in Australien kaufen Öl und Gas
kann man aus der Nordsee bekommen von
verschiedenen Ländern darf man nicht so
viel Kriegen in Norwegen gab es gerade
ein Erdbeben weil die sehr viel Gas aus
der Erde holen das ist für die zum Teil
das mal logisch gefährlich darf nicht zu
viel sein aber ich wiederhole noch mal
USA Kanada Europa Australien
Kreispolitik Uli zurück man muss
natürlich auch immer sehen was kostet
beispielsweise aus Amerika werden aber
jedenfalls das ist ein zweitrangiges
Argument weil wir müssen los von
Russland und wir müssen Russland sehr
viel stärker sanktionieren als was
bisher tun da bin
ich weil die Entsorgung nicht geklärt
ist ums klar zu sagen und die wird auch
nicht geklärt werden wir noch fünf Jahre
verlängern dagegen habe ich im Prinzip
nichts wenn man das brauchen aber die
Entsorgungsfrage ist immer noch offen
und sie ist überall offen das ist
nirgendwo geklärt und es ist auch nicht
billig und es gibt zum Beispiel können
wir uns da ja ein Beispiel an China zum
Beispiel nehmen das habe ich beim
letzten Mal schon angeregt aber keiner
kannte sich scheinbar damit aus das ist
die sind diese Thorium Reaktoren die in
China entwickelt werden das sind
Reaktoren die eigentlich ähnlich
funktionieren wie ein Kernkraftwerk aber
sie sind viel kleiner und produzieren
viel viel weniger Atommüll und vor allen
Dingen das was man dazu braucht das
kriegen wir alles hier aus unserem Boden
wir brauchen keine seltenen Erden kaufen
oder irgendwas es ist eine preiswerte
und relativ
umweltfreundliche
Energieversorgung die man vielleicht
einsetzen könnte bis man wirklich alles
andere technisch so auf den Stand
gebracht haben uns fehlen einfach nur
die Wissenschaftler die sitzen in China
die sitzen sonst wo die sind sie jetzt
schon wieder schneller als wir sehr
viele in Deutschland im Ernst die sind
alle stillgelegt worden weil alle
reaktorlinien es gibt ja wie sie zu
rechts an ganz verschiedener atomare
Entwicklungslinien die sind alle
eingestellt worden also wir waren ja zum
Teil auch bei kleinen
kugelhaufenreaktoren und anderen weniger
gefährlichen reaktor-typen die sind zum
Teil schon hier gebaut worden im Versuch
uns alles vorbei ich würde gerne wieder
aktivieren aber wohl nennt man den Müll
hin das ist die ungeklärte Farbe
aber man kann nicht darauf von ausgehen
wo bringt man Müll hin und schaltet
Atom ab schaltet Kohle ab und hat keine
Alternativen nämlich ich bin ja hier für
die alternativen insofern recht dass man
die die noch bestehenden Kernkraftwerke
ein paar Jahre verlängert das sagen
alles geht gar nicht viel zu teuer und
so weiter wenn man es braucht muss man
es tun der Meinung bin ich auch nach wie
vor in Afrika entstehen 900
Kohlekraftwerke in Südostasien 5000
sollen entstehen Kohlekraftwerke
Klimawandel hört nicht an der deutschen
Außengrenze auf also man muss
zielgerichtet überlegen wie kann man es
lösen und entweder es gibt nur die zwei
Varianten weltweit dafür stehe ich und
kämpfe dafür auch entweder Atomenergie
oder Wüstenstrom es gibt nur die zwei
Varianten und dann es gibt die grüne
den Atomenergie aus den Nachbarländern
kaufen oder von Ländern wo die Reaktoren
nicht so sicher sind wie bei uns dann
und für teureres Geld dann bringt das ja
auch nichts wir brauchen schon
Alternativen weil letztendlich ist die
Kernenergie nicht das pudelskern und die
beste Lösung wir sollten schon dass
irgendwie eliminieren irgendwann aber es
gibt Alternativen wir müssen uns einfach
nur
denken die Strompreise explodieren die
Energiepreise im Allgemeinen und warum
explodieren die weil wir eine höhere
höhere Nachfrage haben und das Angebot
fällt das ist ja schlichtweg der Punkt
und mit Wüstenstrom können wir zumindest
das Angebot erhöhen also was in der
deutschen Debatte über die Frage der
Energiepreise unter Versorgung nicht
öffentlich mitdiskutiert wird ist ja die
Frage Liebe Nena da du immer sagst was
kostet das dann ist die Frage
woher man nennt man die Preise auch
nicht woher man ich bin ja keine
energiefachmann ja
ist die Frage dass das Abschalten von
Gasversorgung zur Heizung von Wohnungen
sich überhaupt nicht stellt weil nach
den geltenden deutschen Gesetzen die
Wohnungen bis zum Schluss versorgt
werden und das ist ungefähr ein Drittel
dass das Bedarfs und dann kommt die
Industrie oben drauf die allerdings ist
dann je nach Branche ist die gefährdet
wenn an den Gas abgeschaltet wird aber
das sagt ja sogar Herbig bis zum
Jahresende haben wir gar kein Problem
also bis zum nächsten Winter warum sagt
dieses Land nicht ich rede jetzt über
Sanktionen gegen Russland warum ist
dieses Land nicht in der Lage zu sagen
wir steigen jetzt aus und üben maximalen
Druck auf Putin aus und sagen bis zum
nächsten Winter das schaffen wir den
Satz haben wir schon mal gehört ich
glaube auch das können wir schaffen die
Diskussion können wir jetzt nicht
aufmachen denn auch sie wartet eine
kurze Unterbrechung und dann geht es
hier weiter mit Hans Ulrich Jörges der
über die Lage der nicht geimpften
Bevölkerung in Deutschland sprechen
möchte bis gleich
[Musik]
noch vier Tage das Box Highlight live
bei Bild
[Musik]
Felix Sturm auf dem Weg zum
Weltmeistertitel
der Kampf gegen Island Chili
willkommen zurück im Regen die bildbox
Nacht Samstag bei Bild
diese Sendung wird präsentiert von
Governor of Poker 3 die gratis Poker App
fürs Handy
Bild
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
Zuschauer bei viertel nach acht und wir
legen jetzt direkt los mit dem Statement
von Hans Ulrich Jörges zu der Lage der
nicht geimpften Menschen in Deutschland
in der vergangen Woche habe ich hier
die ungeimpften symbolisch und
Verzeihung gebeten wegen der Hetze und
der Diskriminierung der sie über viele
Monate ausgesetzt waren die Reaktion war
überwältigend ist und zum Teil sehr
emotional ich habe daraus gelernt über
dieses Thema müssen wir öffentlich reden
es ist notwendig dass wir besprechen
dass es Millionen von Menschen gibt in
Deutschland die zutiefst verletzt sind
weil andere Millionen sich überhaupt
nicht um geschert haben was mit ihnen
passiert das geht nicht weiter so und
haben die Medien auch eine ganz ungute
Rolle gespielt es gibt viele Übergriffe
aus den Medien ich will ein paar
erwähnen im Morgenmagazin des ZDF sind
ungeimpfte als Verfassungsfeinde
bezeichnet worden beim Berliner
Tagesspiegel ist der wunderbare
Kolumnist Harald Martenstein aus dem
Blatt geekelt worden weil er geschrieben
hatte wenn ungeimpfte mit dem Judenstern
auf Demonstrationen zögen dann sei das
zwar anmaßend aber nicht antisemitisch
das ist zweifelsfrei richtig aus meiner
Sicht dann sind beim rbb die ungeimpften
Mitarbeiter über Nacht aus dem Sender
geworfen worden das ist am Tag vor
Weihnachten verkündet worden ich
persönlich bin in einem rufmörderischen
Artikel als Schutzpatron der ungeimpften
bezeichnet worden das hatte die Absicht
mich journalistisch zu erledigen ich
weiß also ein bisschen wovon ich rede
aber ich bin ja geimpft und nicht
ungeimpft und ich finde wir müssen hier
wir müssen hier öffentlich etwas für
diese Menschen tun der Bundespräsident
hat dazu zunächst mal muss ich einwerfen
wir haben uns ja inzwischen was die
Basis der ganzen Diskussion angeht daran
gewöhnt wir haben eingesehen das ist was
die
infektionsleistung angeht also die
Ansteckungsgefahr angeht keinen
Unterschied zwischen geimpfen und
ungeimpften gibt und das ist außerdem in
den in den
Intensivstationen geimpfte neben
ungeimpften liegen da können wir gar
keinen Unterschied mehr feststellen
trotzdem wird aber diese Kampagne gegen
die ungeimpften fortgesetzt ich möchte
einen Satz aus der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung vom gesamt
vom vergangenen Wochenende vorlesen
Zitat und wer sich bis heute keine
Spritze hat geben lassen die Maßnahmen
für übertrieben und das Virus für
harmlos hält sollte ohnehin nicht der
Erste sein der seine Freiheit
zurückbekommt das ist eine ungeheuerer
Satz das heißt in diesem Land gibt es
zwei Sorten von Freiheit die erste
Klasse haben diejenigen die sie haben
impfen lassen und die zweite Klasse
haben vielleicht diejenigen die sich
nicht am impfen lassen der
Bundespräsident hat kürzlich gesagt
es gäbe eine der hat die die Stille
Mehrheit wie er es genannt hat im Land
aufgerufen sie sollten sich zu Wort
melden mit der stillen Mehrheit meinte
er die geimpften die sollten sich gegen
die ungeimpften zu Worte melden ich
finde eher selbst sollte sich zu Wort
melden um den ungeimpften ihre Rechte
zurückzugeben und ihnen Gerechtigkeit
widerfahren zu lassen wir brauchen kein
Bundespräsidenten der eine Mehrheit
auffiegelt wir brauchen einen der die
Minderheit schützt
also zu dem Thema kann ich nur sagen so
wie ich es lebe und auch eigentlich die
meisten in meinem Umfeld ich verhalte
mich so dass ich möglichst andere nicht
gefährde
und sind sie denn geimpft ich bin
Geburtstag und ich werde mich auch ein
viertes Mal ich werde wenn es jemand
sagt der von Medizin mehr Ahnung hat als
ich und das sind ganz viele und wenn die
sagen du musst dich zweimal im Jahr
impfen lassen dann werde ich es machen
nicht nur zum eigenen Schutz sondern
auch um sicher zu gehen dass mein Umfeld
geschützt ist und auch
uns dabei zu unterstützen dass die
Pandemie irgendwann vorbei ist dass wir
ein annähernd normales Leben führen
können dass wir auf Partys gehen können
dass ihr wieder Spaß haben können dass
ich nicht wenn ich im Zug sitze ein
Versprechen was nie eingelöst wurde also
geimpft und gebustert und was ja also
das und trotzdem dürfen die Leute ja
nicht ich finde es schlimm dass ich fünf
Stunden im Zug sitzen muss mit einer
Maske und mir ist dann übel hinterher
und ich will dass das irgendwann mal
aufhört und ich tue alles dafür dass das
irgendwann mal aufhört für uns hier in
Deutschland und das ist mir wichtiger
als dass es eventuell eine Nebenwirkung
gibt oder dass ich meine demokratische
Freiheit ausleben kann mir ist alles
andere wichtiger als diese beiden Punkte
die ich eben oftmals höre und vor allen
Dingen wie gehe ich auch nicht auf die
Straße und
demonstriere und ich lassen erstmal ich
will auch keine Menschen keine Politiker
tätig angreifen weil die andere Meinung
sind dass ich möchte das meine Meinung
respektiert wird genauso wie ich auch
die Meinung der ungeimpften respektiere
und sage wenn du da Ängste hast und es
nicht machen willst aus irgendwelchen
Gründen dann mach es nicht so sehe ich
das auch das Schlimme ist dass die die
Pandemie bei manchen die Sehnsucht nach
Einfachheit sich dann so auswirkt
moralische Rigorosität Sündenbock suche
Sündenbock denken einerseits muss ich in
Jorges ein bisschen widersprechen es
gibt schon noch einen Unterschied bei
der Viruslast und auch bei der Schwere
der Erkrankung zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften aber trotzdem für mich ist
ganz wichtig als Liberale es ist die
Entscheidung von erwachsenen Menschen
selbst welche medizinischen Eingriffe
sie an sich vornehmen lassen und das
muss ich respektieren und der
Unterschied ist allerdings unter Omicron
erst recht nicht mehr so stark
was das Thema Infektionsrisiko und so
weiter angeht deshalb bin ich gegen eine
Impfpflicht ich glaube auch nicht
übrigens dass manche ungeimpften die
sich so ein bisschen jetzt allgemein als
Opfer stilisieren oder als seien sie
mündiger als alle die sich geimpft haben
das ist genauso falsch aber ich habe was
gegen diese Suche nach Sündenböcken und
ganz gefährlich an dem was sie gerade
zitiert haben ist nämlich diese denke
als ginge es um Bestrafung oder
Belohnung im freiheitlichen Rechtsstaat
ist das keine Frage von Gnade oder
Wohlwollen ob man Freiheit hat sondern
der Staat darf nur so wenig wie möglich
so viel wie unbedingt nötig die
Freiheitsrechte einschränken und da und
das ist einfach so schlimm dieses
bevormundende dieses erzieherische
dieser Impetus und der greift immer mehr
um sich wir müssen noch mal erkennen
dass wir unsere Erwartungen ans impfen
ich bin genauso wie sie gebustert
ständig zurückgenommen haben anfangs
haben wir gedacht wenn wir geimpft sind
stecken wir uns auch gar nicht mehr an
und wir können auch andere nicht
anstecken das wurde auch übrigens mit
der maskenpflicht verbunden dann haben
wir gemerkt das stimmt ja gar nicht
sondern wir sind als gepustetes selber
in der Lage andere Menschen anzustecken
ich habe im Moment meine beiden Töchter
und deren Männer sind alle geboostet und
alle Corona krank im selben Moment die
haben gar keinen Umgang mit ungeimpften
weil sie da drauf achten das haben sie
also von bekommen
ich werde ab jetzt nur noch sagen
Menschen die sich gegen die Impfung
entschieden haben
geimpft ungeimpft sind glaube ich zwei
Plakette die wir wieder rauskriegen
wenn ich hier so einen kleinen Vortrag
halte dann muss ich ihn einfach einen
Begriff dafür haben und es ist wird
jeder verstehen dass ich ihn nicht böse
meine tue ich auch nicht also wir haben
uns dann immer weiter zurückgezogen bis
auf den jetzigen letzten bis auf die
letzte Insel dass wir sagen wir geimpft
ist ist jedenfalls geschützt vom
schweren Krankheitsverlauf das stimmt
auch nicht ganz weil das Liegen
gebusterte auf den Intensivstationen die
auch schwer krank sind und es sterben
auch gepustet also ist alles sehr
fragwürdig ich will jetzt nichts gegens
impfen sagen bin dreimal geimpft aber
jedenfalls die sich nicht haben impfen
lassen dafür verantwortlich machen dass
das der die Infektionsraten Ste und dass
das Land nicht rauskommt aus der
Pandemie das ist eine wirklich üble
Geschichte
ist das schwarz-weißt den
Bundespräsidenten die Impfung bringt
weder den absoluten Ausgang aus der
Pandemie wie ist die Impfpflicht
Befürworter behaupten aber es ist auch
falsch wie es die Impfgegner behaupten
dass sie nichts nütze und nicht sinnvoll
sein sie ist für die allermeisten
Menschen in sinnvoller Schutz vor einem
schweren Verlauf aber sie bringt eben
nicht den völligen die völlige
Sicherheit und den völligen Ausgang aus
der Familie
differenzieren ich habe gemerkt an dem
was das an Reaktionen kam auf meine
Bitte um Verzeihung das war eine
symbolische Geschichte wir haben hier
immer Nena und ich haben immer der
Verunglimpfung der der nicht geimpften
widersprochen aber
dass die ungeimpften die dich da
gemeldet haben
rechtsradikal wären oder
Verschwörungstheoretiker oder sonstige
Spinner das kann ich nicht sagen sondern
ich glaube mein Eindruck war das sind
Menschen aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft
und das müssen wir endlich mal begreifen
dass das keine Randfiguren sind
irgendwie obskur sondern sind mitten aus
der Gesellschaft das sind Ärzte dabei
Rechtsanwälte Krankenschwestern das
wissen wir doch alles Krankenpfleger die
jeweils ihrer individuelle Begründung
haben warum sie sich nicht impfen lassen
möchten das ist auch ein gutes Recht
weil es ist nicht vorgeschrieben und
dann müssen wir sie auch verteidigen und
dürfen sie nicht so niedermachen lassen
wie das passiert ist
Schutzpatron der Mensch die sich gegen
die Impfung entschieden haben doch
eigentlich ein Kompliment anlegen aber
es war damals in vernichtender Absicht
geschrieben weil damals las sich das so
Wertung der die ungeimpften und in in
unter seinen Schutzmantel nimmt der ist
ein ganz typisches Zeichen unserer finde
ich nicht nicht mehr gut Debattenkultur
das nicht mehr über die Qualität der
Argumente beurteilt wird was jemand sagt
sondern darüber wer dafür Beifall
klatscht ist ein Riesenproblem auch für
Politiker man kann das richtige sagen
und man von den falschen Leuten Beifall
kriegt wird es darüber diffamiert und
das ist falsch wir müssen doch in der
Sache argumentieren und die Qualität der
Argumente auseinander nehmen und nicht
danach irgendwie sich richten wir
applaudiert oder nicht sonst gibt man
übrigens auch den falschen Leuten die
ganz große Deutungsarbeit denjenigen die
noch bestimmen was man sagen darf oder
was nicht wir müssen überall die
Qualität der Argumente streiten genau
dann brauche ich noch ein sachliches
Argument einbringen
und zwar der Hauptgrund warum überhaupt
über eine Impfpflicht gesprochen wurde
oder wo man ermutigt wurde sich zu
impfen das war bevor überhaupt ein
Impfstoff da war hat man gedacht
hoffentlich kommt eine hoffentlich kommt
einer es gab vor zwei Jahren her da hat
man sich geimpft wie sie gerade gesagt
haben und dann dachte man nach der
zweiten Impfung alles gut so wurde es ja
vom vorherigen Gesundheitsminister auch
propagiert dann hieß es okay das Reich
ist doch nicht man braucht eine dritte
Impfung aber es Hauptargument wo es
immer ging warum muss man oder soll man
sich impfen oder warum gibt es ein
Lockdown weil die Intensivstation
komplett überlastet sind das teile ich
nach wie vor wenn die Intensivstation
überlastet sind dann bricht das
Gesundheitssystem zusammen habe ich
erwarte ja von dem Staat insbesondere
von dem deutschen Staat ja
das R dafür in der Lage ist das
Gesundheitssystem
so in wie sagt man auf den schachtwahl
oder so modern zu führen das genau hier
kann Engpass entsteht ja und das ist die
Hauptaufgabe vom Gesundheitsminister
nicht dass er uns einschränkt ja nicht
dass er uns hier einschränkt damit
sondern er ist dafür verantwortlich
nicht noch mal Lockdown noch mal
Einschränkungen und jetzt schon wieder
erzählen in drei oder was im September
Oktober kommt dann die vierte Welle
irgendwann wird es ja schon wieder
Impfung
bleiben beim Thema Freiheit und gehen
weiter zu dem Statement von Frau
Teuteberg heute Abend ja wir müssen
unseren freiheitsmuskel wieder
trainieren denn die der Ausnahmezustand
der letzten zwei Jahre mit tief
greifenden grundrechtseingriffen der
darf nicht zur neuen Normalität werden
ich finde so laufen aber gerade die
Debatten im Land zum Teil denn wenn wir
jetzt zum Glück dafür haben wir Freien
Demokraten gekämpft nicht mehr eine
allgemeine maskenpflicht haben dann ist
das doch kein maskenverbot für alle die
sich schützen wollen und zum Beispiel im
Supermarkt zum Eigenschutz weiter eine
ffp2 getragen ich finde wir müssen
einfach darüber diskutieren die Pandemie
ist nicht vorbei aber ihr Charakter hat
sich verändert die Infektionszahlen bei
Omicron sie sind zwar hoch sie haben
sich aber entkoppelt von der Frage der
Krankenhauseinweisung und erstrechte
intensivpflichtigen Patienten zahlen und
da muss doch in einem freiheitlichen
Staat gelten Eigenverantwortung first
Verbot des second es ist nicht Aufgabe
des Staates die allgemeinen
Lebensrisiken zu minimieren an einem
Staat der auch an verantwortungsfähige
Bürgerinnen und Bürger von denen ausgeht
und da ist im Moment viel zu tun die
Debatte hat sich leider sehr verschoben
wir haben völlig recht ich möchte auch
nicht in einem Land leben wo die
Freiheit nichts mehr gilt dann kann ich
auswandern da lebe ich irgendwo wo ich
Tomatenpflanze und jeden Tag gieße aber
nicht mehr hier weil ich kann an
Deutschland verschiedenes nicht leiden
unter anderem den Umgang mit
Minderheiten wie ich jetzt gelernt habe
als hätte ich nie für möglich gehalten
da müssen wir was aufarbeiten aber ich
möchte in einem freien Land leben und
ich habe in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten beobachtet wie auch in Zeitungen
in Artikeln von Wissenschaftlern
Historikern Politologen der Begriff der
Freiheit zerlegt worden ist als sei der
fragwürdig als kommiss darauf nicht mehr
an wer redet eigentlich heute von
Freiheiten sie als Liberale Politikern
haben das wahrscheinlich auch beobachtet
ich bin darüber erschrocken wenn wir mal
so weit sind dass wir theoretisch
darüber reden dass wir gar keine
Freiheit mehr brauchen sondern das
andere ist wichtiger ist und dass es sie
haben das ja immer wieder sich anhören
müssen das ist die Beschwörer der
Freiheit sind die uns ins Unglück führen
dann müssen wir dann wirklich dann
schrillen bei mir sämtliche Alarmglocken
und dann müssen wir ja möglicherweise
gehen wir irgendwann mal auf die Straße
ich dann auch
haben Sie denn das Gefühl dass sie noch
in einem freiheitlichen Land leben naja
sagen wir mal so ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl dass viele sagen wir wollen
unseren alten Kaiser Wilhelm wieder
haben wieder diese alt diese
Führungspersonen die jetzt sagt wo es
langgeht und selber Entscheidungen
treffen das ist dann schon schwierig und
ich möchte im Moment wirklich kein
Politiker sein weil egal was du machst
du kannst so viel falsch machen das fing
an mit Corona die Einwand dafür die
Entscheidungen die anderen die Gegend
auch jetzt der Krieg man ist dafür man
ist dagegen es ist schwierig aber ich
finde einfach der Ton muss sich
verbessern ich finde Freiheit bedeutet
auch dass man den anderen die Freiheit
lässt seine Meinung zu äußern und man
soll sich selber auch die Freiheit geben
seine Meinung zu ändern weil ganz viele
halten an ihren einmal gefassten Thesen
fest weil sie nicht schwach oder oder
ich habe ein schwaches Rückgrat oder ich
falle um es muss ich auf die FDP
öfter mal anhören nein man muss auch mit
man muss auch sehen dass ich Zeiten
ändern Situationen ändern und dann muss
man flexibel im Kopf sein und Umdenken
da muss man auch den Mut haben zu sagen
damals hat es gepasst jetzt passt es
nicht mehr wir müssen jetzt eine anderen
Weg gehen ohne Angst davor zu haben Lena
du erinnerst dich ich habe mal gesagt
das Recht auf Irrtum gehört zur Freiheit
ich wünsche mir dass das in den Medien
mal selbst kritisch diskutiert wird was
in den Medien in den in den meisten
jedenfalls in den letzten Monaten alles
geschrieben worden ist über diese
Geschichte und was an Irrtümern
verkündet worden ist und Unrecht getan
worden ist gegenüber anderen die eine
andere Meinung vertreten haben man kann
ja heute noch lesen habe ich jetzt
gerade in einer großen über genialen
Zeitung in einem Leitartikel das
eigentlich die maskenpflicht für immer
weiter gelten sollte
wie würde das unser Land verändern wenn
wir ständig wenn wir in ein Supermarkt
kommen auch in drei vier fünf Jahren in
den Maske aufziehen müssen lieber Himmel
dann gehe ich aber hier auch gerne die
Frage Antwort heute weg ich habe auch
diese Angst heute Berg als Bürgerin wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass die
maskenpflicht einfach meine kleine
Schwester die ist 23 hat heute ihre
letzte BWL Klausur geschrieben und ich
habe heute morgen gesagt wie schön
endlich mal wieder eine Klausur ohne
Maske gestern weil der Freedom Day was
am Sonntag Maske ist er jetzt gefallen
dann guckt meine Schwester mir an sagt
nee ich schreibe die ganze Klausur mit
Maske meine Schwester ist geimpft sitzt
da in einem Einzeltisch mit Abstand um
von dem anderen nicht abzuschreiben und
muss ihre Klausur mit Maske schreiben
man hört das denn mal auf also dafür
haben wir gesorgt nach dem zweiten
vierten ist damit Schluss
ja es sei denn sie missbrauchen die
HotSpot Regelung und meinen sie seien
ein flächendeckender Hotspot aber sie
können höchstens bis zum zweiten vierten
das was sie schon als landesregelung
hatten weiter gelten lassen danach
können Sie das nicht mehr als
landesregelung machen wir haben das
begrenzt auf Krankenhäuser Pflegeheime
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr man kann
nicht mehr in Schulen oder am
Arbeitsplatz oder im Supermarkt eine
allgemeine maskenpflicht verhängen die
Hotspots das soll wirklich die
Möglichkeit sein regional zu reagieren
aber es gibt ja leider die Anzeichen
dass einige meinen sie klären einfach
mal ihr ganzes Bundesland zum Hotspot da
ist Wachsamkeit gefordert aber daran wie
viel wie viel Prügel wir einstecken
dafür überhaupt dafür einzustehen dass
man wenn die Situation sich ändert auch
die Gesetze ändern muss und das auch die
Regeln angepasst werden müssen dass das
macht mir eben wirklich Sorge Freiheit
wird diffamiert da wird von
vulgärliberalismus gesprochen ich würde
ja eher sagen wir haben ganz viel vulgär
illiberalismus in diesem Land die
Freiheit wird diffamiert ich habe am
Wochenende gelesener süddeutschen Zeiten
dürfen Suppenkasper Freiheit aber nicht
ein einziges Argument nicht ein
Argument dafür warum diese
schwerwiegenden Grundrechtseingriffe die
wir uns bis vor zwei Jahren nicht hätten
träumen lassen dieser Republik warum die
jetzt gerechtfertigt sein zu verlängern
man wird als ungezogenes Kind
dargestellt wenn man das mal in Frage
stellt vergleichen Sie das noch mal
hinten und zieht die ganze Tischdecke
mit dem ganzen wo sind
bürgerrechtsverteidiger die früher in
der Politik nie gesagt hätten dass jedes
Kriminalitätsopfer ein Grund sei
maximale Überwachung zu fordern diese
Logik ist gefährlich zu sagen jeder
mögliche krankheits- oder Todesfall
rechtfertigt jede scharfe staatliche
Maßnahme
wie empfinden Sie das denn hat für sie
auch die corona-pandemie vielleicht auch
die Staatsgläubigkeit der deutschen zum
Vorschein gebracht dieses vormundhafte
diesen Menschen der Regeln macht den man
will
so um auf das Statement zurückzukommen
ich fühle mich immer noch frei in
Deutschland trotz Maske das ist für mich
ist nicht die alles entscheidende
schlimmste Einschränkung an sich
für mich ist immer noch primär wenn die
Intensivstationen
noch frei Kapazitäten haben kann man
Maske tragen muss es nicht mich nervt
die Maske tatsächlich aber für mich ist
nicht so elementar nicht so eine große
Einschränkung an sich die Maßnahmen viel
mehr die kann ich tatsächlich in Frage
stellen das ist so glaubt noch wer kommt
denn die Bauer auf die Idee
möchten Sie als erwachsener Mann dass
ihnen jemand vorgibt die Entscheidung
sie tragen jetzt die Maske Schröder
wollen sie nicht selber also ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich fühle mich völlig ich
bin 29 Jahre alt ich kann selber
entscheiden wann ich eine Maske tragen
soll war nicht wann ich es tue finden
Sie dass dieser Form und zum Beispiel
Schweden hat ja nie de facto so eine
allgemeine maskenpflicht und auch in
England gibt es das nicht mehr finden
Sie es richtig dass ihnen der Staat
vorschreibt ziehen Sie die Maske auf da
komme ich wieder darauf zurück von vorne
und gesagt hat Verteidigungsministerin
mit Erfahrung oder Gesundheitsminister
mit Erfahrung ich unterstelle
grundsätzlich weil ich den Menschen ich
bin gutgläubiger Mensch vom Grunde her
und wenn man mir sagt es hilft in der
Sache man kann entweder nicht anstecken
und man wird vor allem nicht angesteckt
dann habe ich insbesondere am Anfang
dran geglaubt dass es hilfreich ist ich
habe am Anfang sogar die Maske selbst
freiwillig getragen als noch kann
Impfstoff gab jetzt aufgrund der
Maßnahmen den Zeit am Flughafen darf man
nicht nebeneinander setzen und auf den
Toiletten männertoiletten sind plötzlich
fünf Toiletten zwei in der Mitte
abgedeckt dann steht man hintereinander
geht ins Flugzeug rein sitzen
nebeneinander komplett mit Maske ich
bestelle mir eine Cola oder ein Bier
oder was auch immer und dann Maske
abziehen also das sind Sachen die kann
natürlich nicht nachvollziehen ich will
mal was positives erzählen Moment
unbedingt keine Zeit mehr für Frauen
Samstag mein Wochenmarkt am Prenzlauer
Berg da sind nur noch höchstens zehn
Prozent obwohl der Maske vorgeschrieben
ist mit Maske rumgelaufen die anderen
haben sie nicht mehr getragen zwar ein
herrliches Gefühl Freiheit sehr gut
damit hast du wieder der Schlusswort zu
dem Thema
Frau geht'ser mit ihrem Thema und da
ändern wir jetzt meinen Kurs weniger
befreit obwohl vielleicht hat es im
großen Sinne doch etwas damit zu tun ja
natürlich hat es auch was mit Freiheit
zu tun wir haben ja alle in der letzten
Zeit uns sehr verändert und sind sehr
locker geworden und sehr tolerant und
das Transgendern gehört ja auch dazu
aber es gibt natürlich auch Bereiche wo
es überhandnimmt zum Beispiel in Amerika
der Thomas die ist eine Schwimmerin aber
es ist eigentlich als Mann geboren und
hat Schwamm auch als Mann aber dann
meinte sie doch ihren
doch dazu zu stehen dass sie doch
eigentlich eher eine Frau ist und bei
Wettkämpfen schwimmt sie jetzt
sämtlichen Frauen davon ganz klar als
Mann hat sie breitere Schultern völlig
andere Muskulatur ist viel kräftiger und
das ist finde ich gegenüber den
biologischen Frauen schon mega
weil gerade es gibt viele Sportarten da
ist nun mal ein Riesenunterschied und
ich bin der Meinung da sollte es ein
Regelung gehen weil ich finde natürlich
auch das Transgender die Möglichkeit
haben sollen Sport zu treiben aber da
muss man wirklich Regelungen finden es
gibt auch Sportarten wo es nicht so
wichtig ist oder aber man sagt ihm wie
beim Boxen es gibt vom Delta und fliegen
bis zum Schwergewicht unterschiedliche
Klassen vielleicht kann man da solche
Regelungen einführen aber das was jetzt
so langsam auch in anderen
Sportbereichen schon Schule macht das
sollte man schnellen Riegel vorsetzen
weil das ist den Frauen gegenüber
ungerecht vor allen Dingen den Frauen
die früher in der DDR oder auch in China
männliche Hormone gespritzt bekommen
haben die dann verteufelt wurden die
medizinisch körperlich fertig gemacht
wurden durch das Doping und jetzt mit
einem Mal passiert so etwas das stimmt
etwas absolut nicht ja ich finde es
beraubend mit welcher
Selbstverständlichkeit frühere Männer in
frauenwettbewerber eintreten die wissen
doch wie unfair das ist man stelle ich
mal vor einer der Klitschko-Brüder würde
ins Frauenboxen gehen und sagen ich bin
jetzt eine Frau ja und dann kämpft da
Schwergewicht gegen eine halben Meter
kleinere Frau die auch halb so breit ist
wie er das ist doch völlig unmöglich das
muss natürlich von den
Sportorganisationen untersagt werden
ganz einfach oder das muss unbedingt
untersagt werden und es gibt ja auch die
Möglichkeit zum Beispiel vor vielen
Jahren die parinha
thailändische Kickboxen drin also ein
Kickboxer aber in Thailand ist es ja da
ist Transgendern
also ich als Frau ich erkenne das sofort
aber für Männer fallen drauf rein auf
jeden Fall hat die eben im
reichslandschaften gewonnen aber sie hat
eben geschminkt und schickt zurecht
gemacht gegen Männer gefaltet und hat
gewonnen und das ist richtig so sollte
man machen man kann ja sich ausleben und
ich finde auch Transgender sollten die
Möglichkeit haben Sport zu machen aber
doch bitte in ihrer Gewichtsklasse und
und ich finde es nicht schön den
Fußballer oder auch Boxer oder egal
welche Sportler aufgrund ihrer sexuellen
Neigung diskriminiert werden das ist ein
Problem ich glaube was uns noch nicht
gelungen ist bei diesem Thema wenn es um
ja gesellschaftliche Toleranz und so
geht ist mal zu differenzieren zwischen
Respekt vor der Identität wie sich ein
Mensch fühlt wie er sein Privatleben
führen will oder wie er seine Identität
geschlechtlich sieht und andererseits
trotzdem ein paar biologischen Fakten
die eine Rolle spielen weshalb es eben
verschiedene die verschiedenen
Sportarten für Männer und Frauen
getrennt gibt oder auch verschiedene
andere Dinge für Männer und Frauen
getrennt angeboten werden dass wir das
Trennen von der Frage nicht das eine ist
besser oder schlechter oder Geschlechter
irgendwie anders aufwerten oder abwerten
oder sagen Männer oder bauen können
irgendwas nicht aber trotzdem die
Sachlichkeit zu haben es gibt
biologische Tatsachen die eine
Auswirkung haben die auch zählen in
bestimmten Bereichen nicht im Sinne von
höher oder schlechter wertig aber das
mal zu trennen und ich glaube das
gelingt noch nicht und wenn so ist sonst
so viel heißt follow the science
Fakten sehen dann glaube ich brauchen
wir darüber noch mal eine Debatte wie
geht man damit klug um mit dem Respekt
vor unterschiedlichen Gefühlen und
Identitäten einerseits und den
biologischen Fakten andererseits da
stehen wir noch ziemlich am Anfang also
da ist glaube ich wirklich noch einiges
zu tun auch mit der
Selbstverständlichkeit des Umgangs denn
gerade wenn man jetzt eben anfängt zum
Beispiel wurde ich ja von der
Bild-Zeitung mal aufgeforderten
Interview zu führen weil jetzt das
Buchstabieren nicht mehr mit A wie Anton
und Baby Berta und so weil das ja
irgendwie Geschlechter spezifisch ist
sondern man sollte jetzt Städtenamen
dafür nehmen ich finde es ist ein völlig
falsches
selbstverständlich wie man eben mit
Transgendern umgeht ist das nicht
wichtig sie wollen respektiert werden
und sie wollen
gleichberechtigt sein und sie wollen
gleiche Voraussetzungen nahmen aber
natürlich nur so wie es auch geht und
ich bin Sport eine Frage stellen wie
reagieren denn die Zuschauer auf so
Wettbewerbe pfeifen die dann wenn der
wenn der frühere Mann oben auf aber es
gab auf Twitter immer
ich habe meine Lösung mit dabei
vielleicht könnte man ja einfach dann
wenn es dann mehr werden
Transgender Olympische Spiele machen so
ist es wo genau dann für die Gruppe aber
da wäre dann auch das Problem wieder
wenn ein Mann zu einer Frau wird ist es
ja auch wieder anders als wenn eine Frau
zu einem Mann wird auch da hätten wir
wieder die Gewichtsunterschiede aber er
Schröder wie sehen Sie das denn setzt
nicht dieser Fall eigentlich komplett
das Leistungsprinzip außer Kraft
es gibt gewisse Punkte wo es clevers zu
schweigen
das ist jetzt sozusagen das hat mir
meine Frau bei der Sendung auch geraten
ein einer davon wir waren ja letzte
Woche gemeinsam auf einer Hummeln und
Top-Veranstaltung war eine super
Veranstaltung gegen mit Männern und
Frauen Männer und Frauen aber natürlich
ist er kann auch eine gewisse Dynamik
entstehen deshalb wie wenn viele Männer
zusammen sind im Fußball sondern so eine
Gruppendynamik andersrum bei Frauen kann
es genauso passieren und manchmal ist
danach einfach besser
man sagt wenn man davon keine Ahnung hat
wie eine Politik soll es ja auch sein
sollte macht man in der Lage sein zu
sagen ich habe keine Ahnung oder ich
äußere mich zu diesem Thema am besten
nicht ja sehr sehr
könnt ihr denn die Lösung aussehen es
ist ja jetzt das Beispiel mit dem
Schwimmen ist jetzt ein Beispiel was
wird sich ja in vielen Disziplinen noch
stellen was könnte denn eine Möglichkeit
sein einfach die Leute in den Klassen zu
lassen guter Vorschlag was du gemacht
hast also wenn es wirklich genug
Menschen werden auf die das zutrifft
dann könnte man natürlich eigenständige
Wettbewerbe austragen aber ich glaube
das ist noch schwierig im Moment stehen
insbesondere die weiblichen
Sportlerinnen davon aus schwierigen
Entscheidung nämlich ob sie boykottieren
oder sich in einem unfairenen Wettbewerb
begeben die müssen dramatisch und das
und das kann so finde ich nicht sein wie
das im Moment läuft biologische Männer
dann Vorteile haben und am Ende der
Leistungsgedanke des Sports nicht mehr
funktioniert dass sie von gleichen
körperlichen Voraussetzungen ausgehen
die da miteinander Frauen nicht in die
Situation gebracht werden dass sie
boykottieren müssen das ist Aufgabe der
Sportverbände das zu klären aber es gibt
ja auch Sportarten die die man ruhig
machen kann zum Beispiel der Reitsport
oder schießen also es gibt einige
Sportarten ja doch die nicht von der
Muskelkraft sondern eher von
Geschicklichkeit oder Konzentration
abhängig sind Schach
ja und insofern sollte man sich
vielleicht erst mal als Transgender auf
diese Sportarten das übergeben wir den
Sportverein weil wir sind am Ende
unserer Sendung angekommen und ich
möchte die heute gerne mit den Worten
von Frau Teuteberg beenden
Eigenverantwortung first-verbote second
das war für mich der Satz heute Abend
bei 8:15 Uhr schönen Abend ihnen noch
und hoffentlich bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]